So most of these top three programming languages, videos, they always start.
By saying it depends because blah, blah, blah, blah. I won't say that.
I'm just going to give it to you.
So the top three programming languages depends what you're trying.
And optimize for. Wow. What a hypocrite. Anyways,
this video is sponsored by Skillshare.
So I've bucketed into three main categories or like main purposes for learning a
new language. And I think that encompasses most of you. Now.
I want you guys to be honest with yourself,
because I do think that 95% of you guys who say that you want to go
into computer science because it is your passion. You are lying to yourselves.
Now that 95%, they actually care about money, the lifestyle,
or the promise that you'll be able to build a startup that will make you
billions.
Now that is totally fine because there's nothing wrong in choosing a career for
its financial advantages that is called making informed life
decisions. But don't lie to yourself. Be honest because Earl's,
you might end up hating what you do. But if you're honest, if yourself,
you will understand the trade-off that you made and you accept the setbacks and
the negative outcomes of your life also don't feel bad that you
suddenly realized her lying to yourself. I've lied to myself. Many times.
I lied to myself saying that I want to be a doctor when I was 13,
because it was my passion to help other people get better.
But obviously as Asians,
we all know what the true reason we want to be doctors
so that we can touch boobies. Right. All right.
So now that you're honest with yourself,
put yourself in one of these three camps.
One I want to program 'cause. I want a tech job at a big tech company.
Two.
I want to program because I want to build web apps fast so that I could make
my own product or work for an early startup three.
I want to program so that I could be ahead.
When I start computer science next year, as a freshmen,
I'll also make one assumption. You haven't programmed that much,
or you are a beginner because I don't think most experienced programmers care
about the top languages. They know that most languages are kind of similar.
And what they care about is more about what frameworks or engineering
domain they should focus on. All right. So depending on which camp you're in,
I'm going to give you the top three programming languages.
Now I'm going to give those to you so that once you start learning stuff,
that's actually important like engineering domains or frameworks,
you don't need to relearn these languages so that at least you can get that out
of the way. For example,
imagine if your goal was to do machine learning or play with
data and fit some models, then I would say, you should go with Python,
but learning Python has nothing to do with learning machine learning.
But it's just that once you get to machine learning,
most probably you will use the language Python because of the like
PI torch and stuff like that. All right. So let's start with,
I want to program because I want a tech job at a big tech company. Now,
before we go into that,
I want to tell you how the recruiting process works at these big tech companies.
You have three stages, right? The first one is to get an interview.
And then the second stage is to pass the interview.
And then the third stage is to do well in your job. AKA not get fired.
Ask yourself what is my limiting factor? Is it that I can't get the interviews?
Or is it that I can't pass the interviews? Or is it that once I get the job,
I'm not doing very well. And I don't like it.
So think of it as a funnel and understand what your limiting factor is.
And then work on that. If your resume is not picked up by D interviewer,
then it doesn't matter how great of a software engineer you are,
because you're never going to get to that bottom of the funnel.
You're never going to get to start working.
Then there's no chance for you to show off your awesome software engineering
skills. That's just how life is unfortunately.
So if your limiting factor is not being able to get interviews,
then that means you have to work on your resume.
And if you will have to work on your resume,
it means you have to have work experience there,
but you can't have work experience if you've never gotten a job.
So the alternative is getting referrals and in combination having
good personal projects for your resume. However,
if your problem is that you can't pass the interviews,
then that means you just have to up your data structure and algorithm skills.
And that means Lea coding, especially for these big tech companies,
because that's what they test you on.
If your problem is that you can't do your job well, once you get in there,
then most of the time, it's not because of our technical abilities,
but it's more about your resourcefulness and how independent I am kind of
skills. All right.
So here's the top three languages for beginners who want to eventually get into
a big tech company doing a tech job. So number one, Python,
number two, Java and number three C plus,
plus these three languages are the best for big tech companies
during coding interviews. And that is what you should be optimizing for.
If you have to put time into one thing,
then I strongly recommend that thing to be leak coding.
Many people have been able to get into jobs like Facebook or Google just
by being good at solving these leak code questions.
Even though some of them might not even know what get is or build files are
crazy now for interviews,
I think using Python is your best bet because it is not typed.
You don't need to do memory management.
And there are a lot of shortcuts that make it easier for you to code during your
interview. And that is extremely important because each line of code,
if you save about one or two seconds, that adds up to a lot.
And also you don't need to use your brain to think about the syntax or
a particular language stuff so that you have more time or more space in your
brain to think about the actual problem itself.
Python is also really good because many of the web frameworks like Django and
flask are in Python and these frameworks are really good for you to make
personal projects.
And these projects will translate well into your resume to get interviews.
I put Java and C plus plus there,
because I guarantee you that a big tech company,
at least one part of their system is written in Java or C plus plus C plus
plus is usually used for more complex systems when performance is
really important, Java, less so,
but it's a great language to build applications. Like for example,
LinkedIn uses it, uh, two Sigma uses it. Palentier uses it. Now,
yes, I put Java and C plus plus below Python,
but they do have one thing over Python.
Your curriculum at school is probably using Java or C plus
plus most universities.
I don't think they will teach in Python because Python is not
a great language to learn fundamentals like types or, um, you know,
building and compiling and memory management. You don't need that in Python.
So that's why they prefer not to teach those things in Python because
Python is an interpreted language. If you don't understand what that means,
don't worry about it because eventually you will. That's how we learn stuff.
We just hear, we just hear a lot of things that gets repeated to us.
And over time we connect the dots and then we realize, Oh, that's what it meant.
Python, Java, and C plus plus have tremendous support in Lea code.
Usually when they give you answers or solutions to the problems,
they give it to you in these three languages. Yeah.
So then I put C plus plus below Java because C plus plus is
a very wordy language and that's going to slow you down during interviews.
So that's why C plus plus is at third place. All right.
So if your goal is to build stuff like build web applications and build them
fast and have fun with them,
then I think the top three programming languages are JavaScript,
Java and Swift. This might be a little bit controversial,
but I'll explain it later. Now, if you're like, Ooh, JavaScript,
this is a trash language, shut up, stop regurgitating.
What you've read on the internet and have your own opinions for Christ's sakes.
Before I explain why I chose these programming languages,
let me explain how web apps are built.
You have a front end and then you have your business logic in your backend.
And then you have storage for your data.
That is usually how web apps are formed to reiterate. You have the front end,
that displays to your users.
And then you have the backend that decides what to display depending on your
data that you have. And then you also have storage to store your data.
For example, if you're making online tic-tac-toe,
then the front end you displayed the grid for the players to interact with.
And then the backend, you have the logic of saying, Oh, if that's the case,
he wins. If that's the case, she wins. If that's the case, that's a draw.
And then on the data storage side,
you store in memory or whatever the state of the game. All right.
So now that you understand front end and backend of a web app,
let me explain to you why I think JavaScript is number one.
And also why I said that my list was a little bit controversial. Now.
I think my list is a little bit controversial because Python is not in there.
Python is extremely popular for building backends for web applications.
Lamp stack was very popular. Back then lap is Linux Apache,
my sequel and PHP.
And then PHB got replaced by Python over time.
And Python became very, very popular.
So a lot of frameworks like Django and flask made a popular,
I actually use Django a lot back when I was in college,
I built a website called porn Dora, but, uh, that's a story for another time.
So yes, Python was really popular,
but then Google released their V8 engine. And then also concurrently,
no JS came along,
which is a runtime environment for JavaScript that caused a bunch of web
frameworks for Java script to pop up, for example, express,
especially because these web frameworks were so new,
they were built with scale in mind,
older frameworks didn't anticipate the scale that we would be operating at.
So they're at a disadvantage compared to the newer sexier
frameworks that optimizes on throughput and scalability because of their event
driven architecture, capable of asynchronous IO.
So using node JS as your backend is extremely popular for
pet projects or even startups. Now, you know,
Tinder uses no JS for their backend. If you know what have been no,
but I'm serious. They actually use no JS of bender.
What's great about Java script is that it's also good for front end now,
you know, websites it's built in HTML, CSS and Java script,
and then also front end frameworks and libraries.
You have react and angular JS. In addition,
even for mobile apps,
you now have react native where you can build iOS app
and Android app by using JavaScript. No JS are, I mean,
Java script is the only language that you can solely use to build a
whole app end to end. All right, next,
I put Java and Swift.
The reason why I put Java in Swift is because for mobile development,
you need Java for Android, and then you need Swift for iPhones.
So as you can see,
I never really talked about the specifics or the features of a language.
If you're watching this videos,
I highly doubt that you would care about the intricacies of a programming
language.
What you should care is how much support do you have on the internet for that
language or purpose you're trying to accomplish. For example,
C plus plus is a great language to build performance systems.
But if you want to do data stuff,
there isn't that much popular support for data frame style libraries.
So it's a crappy language. If you want to do data stuff.
Now on the other hand,
R is a great language for numerical computation,
but if you want to build web applications for it,
I don't think you have that much support because it's just not that popular to
use R to build web applications.
I'm pretty sure someone made a web application framework,
but if there aren't that many people who use it,
then there isn't that much support for it.
And then every time you're going to Google something,
you're not going to find the answer.
So before you jump into a language and build a web app,
what you should do is that you should build a small project and then Google
your way through your answers. And then if you could see that, wow,
every time I Google something, I get an answer right away on stack overflow.
Then it means this language has a lot of support and you should use it,
but if not, then not so much.
And then once you find that that language is probably the best for your use
case, because you have the support of the whole internet, all right.
Now, for the final bucket for you,
people who want to get ahead before starting computer science as a
freshmen, from what I understand, uh,
what I said before is that they usually use Java or C plus plus for their
courses. For me, when I was in Waterloo,
the first programming language they taught us in was something called scheme,
which was a functional programming language. And then later on,
they taught us using C Nazi plus plus C because they wanted
to teach us memory management so that we understand the fundamentals of memory
more. And then later on, we use C plus plus,
so that we learned about object oriented programming.
And then depending on your electives, you could usually use whatever you want,
whatever that gets the job done,
but mostly they make you use Java or C plus plus things that require high
performance.
You'd usually want a language that you could compile into binary and then run
it. So for example, C plus plus is a very popular choice for graphics.
And then C is a also very popular choice for low-level things.
So usually in OSTP classes or embedded systems classes,
you're going to be using C I personally like C plus plus more just
because I think once you learn the language and the fundamentals of
it, it's pretty easy to port over other languages, but that's just my opinion.
But anyways, that's pretty much it. Thank you for listening.
Peace out. Thank you so much Skillshare for sponsoring this video.
Skillshare is an online community with thousands of classes,
covering dozens of creative and entrepreneurial skills,
explore classes and everything like from web development to freelance and
entrepreneurship to graphic design and more premium membership gives you
access to high quality classes from experts,
working in their field to help you gain new skills and live your best
life. Skill share is also incredibly affordable. I mean,
they have an annual subscription of less than $10 a month.
I took a few of their premium.
Original classes and I was pleasantly surprised by some of them.
And this one, especially the class is called presentation essentials.
How to share ideas that inspire action by Simon Sineck
in case you don't know Simon Sineck, he is an author and a motivational speaker.
The first time I heard about him is from a viral video where he talks about
millennials in the workplace. I thought he was a great storyteller.
And for me, I think storytelling is an extremely important skill to have.
This class is short sweet and to the point,
and I highly recommend checking it out. So if you're interested,
click on the link in the description down below,
and you're going to get two months of premium skills.
For free check them out.